it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
no green bros first of all we're the
green bros mark's hair is out of control
ladies and gentlemen tell mark looks
it's an absolute [ __ ] mane first of
all i apologize for referring to it as
hair you have a mane i appreciate it
yeah we're on the streets women will be
like can i touch your hair i'm like i
don't get it it's just here well he's
young but it's gray and that's a pretty
cool combo but it's like do you think it
feels different than your hair lady you
both have long hair it's silver it's
thick
have you ever thought about like if you
shaved your head would you would you
suddenly lose all your strength and be
very very insecure yeah that's why i
don't do it uh-huh even though it would
be a weird vibe if he shaved his hair
your hair's looking mighty
brilloy
well from the hat i mean
it was covered in mud i was gonna say
it's from the tough mudder mud tough one
in chicago good pictures
yeah they're fun we ran with the buttery
bros now mark jumped in the ice bath in
the ice water portion of it and came out
and you you would think it was uh low
budget jason momoa
with his shirt yeah i was like what is
happening really yeah
now uh that's a that's great what was
that that was that was theoretical
wow he looks good and then look at me at
theo
jesus let's go to bourbon street and hit
that sax and get some beads
in your face good god
you don't know if a guy's like trying to
shoot you or [ __ ] oh i see his hair
you know pick your poison man yeah i was
like oh so
take your ass to new orleans sam that's
impressive dude so this video of this
guy
a couple of big boys this is the this is
the
the ending that we get electrocuted yeah
and the guy next to me you'll see him on
there he gets he's getting all out of
[ __ ] he's getting crazy and uh he's
like are you gonna stand are you gonna
go i'm like trying to figure out how not
to get shocked like the least i'm like
how can i and mark's like tell me and he
goes we're gonna go or what and i go you
go dude go ahead
watch
go ahead there you go
see he's hitting his chest look
watch this
boom
ripped his beard out
he got [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] that
how much did you get shocked just that
oh because he knocked them all down so
like four of them just all hit me in the
chest wow you heard that so this guy's
annoying how did he why did he fall back
because it wrapped around his beard he
got caught his and wrapped around his
neck oh well that's bad
for him
yeah it was fun though
and uh and he he passed out came too
that jumped so [ __ ] weird and then
they hit then it knocked all the
electric down
and he knocked all of it down so he's
not getting shocked there i didn't know
that so that's why i'm navy seal
crawling there yeah now bubba if he's
doing it i'm looking at his body i feel
like i could do it
i do we were talking about i was talking
about the buttery bros because we're
like halfway it's just a lot it's a lot
if like at your age i don't know why you
you could i think you could do it
it you know
like there's
you know like some girl broke her leg
like some you know multiple people broke
their legs broke their arms like you
gotta i'm not worried about the my wind
my wind's good it's my [ __ ] my calves
my my it's a lot
it's a lot i mean so it's tough for me
it's tough for me to mark like it's not
easy at all how do how do you guys do
against the buttery bros because those
guys are in good shape it should but
no one's like trying to win races like
you're just doing it together yeah we
all stayed together and ran together and
like i'm very happy it was fun bodies
yeah they're great good guys they're
great but like you know
like when you think about like when
people always the worst can happen you
know then i mean
i mean like on the thing where you're on
a like you're doing pull-ups and then
you gotta transition to another thing
and there's water like deep water
underneath you with mud and you're going
around your hands are wet like that girl
fell off snapped her [ __ ] leg that's
not good another guy who snapped his leg
mark rolled his ankle yeah
not good you know
some [ __ ]
it's a bit it's the biggest one they've
had 15 000 people signed up right 15 000
people around that race
minimum sign up 150 bucks think how much
money tough mudders making yeah all you
do is rent that land in the middle of
nowhere you have sponsors but i was
talking about this with the buttery bros
in rain
i would assume their nut comes from uh
insurance
oh right because the liability insurance
has to be through the year yeah oh but
but you also have people sign waivers we
all sign waivers but still right yeah so
you can suck it soon for sure so i'm
sure that's where
a majority
has to be a high
high number yeah right yeah i would
imagine we had fun though but also
chicago like
they all came to my show friday at the
laugh after he shot the left factory
chicago great club have you ever done it
no in like the middle of [ __ ] chicago
it's great so much fun but um
they came there and the head of tough
mudder was there and he's like yeah you
know we do courses worldwide this number
three toughest one i was like really
okay that might be super nervous it was
the i don't think it was the toughest
one i think it was the funnest one like
we went through a river like straight up
a river you're gonna cross
it was dope damn and like the terrain it
wasn't as hard like california what did
you think i think california's tougher
yeah i agree with them
way more pleasant because the
temperature is perfect
the ground is nice there's trees around
to look at versus all the scenery okay
15k yeah
all the scenery is different
it was fun i did uh i went to our boy
tarik's uh wedding in ottawa canada i
was the best man
means brian had to make a speech
brian had to make speech good thing you
can talk
well did you now did that put did brian
put any effort into this that'd be the
question i put a lot of effort into it
the problem is
here's the problem
i'm not good with emotion bubba
uh
so i i
well
my boy uh your your boy made a speech i
i opened it up and i cried
for oh dark
i cried because i mentioned his mom
and i wanted to talk about the sacrifice
see his mother came so so tarek's
mother's father was killed by the
soviets they took him away and she never
saw him again and at 18 years old she
had to leave the country all the mom
yeah my mom okay tarts dad didn't die
though no i know her her her
family so their grandfather was a very
famous uh air force general mm-hmm and
the soviets killed him yep they took him
and put him in jail for three days and
he died god knows what they did to him
yeah
so
whenever you see uh people who are
refugees like that they're very proud
you know they are a very proud family
yeah very proud she's a very proud
strong woman so when you see that and i
remember one time i said to her
what do you miss about afghanistan
and she said everything oh wow i miss
everything
and i said everything and she goes
everything i said like what she goes
even the air that's her home what she
was saying there was i could see the
pain in her face that she would never
show anybody yeah and i and then that's
something that happened we were eating
dinner right it just happened yeah and i
never stopped i think about it every day
for whatever reason yeah like it's two
years ago in a way it was every day is
extreme but you just got done with the
wedding it's in your head though right
you're like you think about how people
have it what they they've gone through
and then she makes those to joseph and
antarctic she makes those two best guys
on the two of the best guys on the
planet yep just because it's both
successful yeah yeah both successes
like joseph now has his own security
company that's killing it tarek has he's
doing [ __ ] everything as usual taking
over the world yeah so so
you know she she did this and i i what i
wanted what i was trying to say is your
sacrifice your pain
made the world a better place it may
feel like you went through a lot of [ __ ]
but look what you created that's what i
was trying to say dude
dude can i get it out what the i i i
couldn't i embarrassed myself oh i
started crying
and you couldn't finish the i was in a
very nice suit start crying in front of
a bunch of people i don't know
in canada and couldn't finish i had to
take
and then i forgot the [ __ ] i was going
to say it was a rambling speech
frankly stop for a rambling speech and i
i
i the only thing that it was worth that
was that i showed them that i love them
but it was i was there's no closest i
was
like that would be better yeah 100
i i'm and i was just and i kept doing
this to myself i kept going [ __ ] yeah
you can't get a you can't get a a take
back you can't get a you can't run it
back no if you're yeah i i mean i cried
about jays when you went you did yeah
yeah big time when you made the speech
yep that was the best man
you can't hold it together but then at
uh deleo's wedding uh
his wife's uh
broom uh were they brooms uh groomsmen
grooms no not the groomers around the
the bridesmaids bridesmaids stories were
all like inside like you remember in the
vortex let me say vortex
girl
and i was like oh that's the worst
speech of all time and then uh they kept
saying it and uh i think it you know
we're like somebody's given the red
light so we need to give them the light
me and you know laughing our asses off
but then uh
uh chris's brother got up crushed it and
then linoche had to follow that you know
leno she had some drinks probably doing
some drugs whatever and then linoche
killed it crushed it he's great yeah
professional yeah all the and then
everyone's like it's the best that
you've ever had wow you could only just
do that every night wow crushed it you
didn't speak no no
no
yeah man when you're talking about
pressure i find weddings
very emotional and i don't know why and
i embarrassed myself i like the
i like when they're walking down the
aisle a lot of stuff and the family's
talking i like that part's emotional but
then after that i'm i'm good i'm good
yeah i'm ready to go maybe part of it
had to do this is my other excuse i it's
like part of it might have had to do
with like we went to this spot called
nordique where you go where where you're
the
michelin star restaurant's there but
it's an outdoor um hot spring okay you
got saunas you got cold plungers you got
more saunas you got eucalyptus and i we
were doing uh uh we were doing it on a
loop
like all the guys and and maybe maybe
the cold and hot got rid of all the
toxins and i was weak
i was
that's not true that's so stupid yeah
yeah
you know who hung out with a lot i was
gonna say who else was there bruce
grankowski uh oh the football player the
quarterback [ __ ] great guy yeah just
a great quarterback for uh tulsa or
tulane just hanging out with a shirt off
and i'm standing next to him i was like
what'd he do now
uh he owns restaurants that's cool yeah
he's doing it he's a great guy
a guy uh another police officer named
vijay who's an old friend of theirs um
uh they were all part of the grooves
yeah just great guys just [ __ ] great
guys man
and watch we shoot this thing and was it
was luke there rock hold no luke's foot
got infected so he couldn't make [ __ ]
yeah his foot's all [ __ ] up any other
football players i mean tark's a big
football guy no not no it was just uh it
was just bruce a lot of people because
it was ottawa oh that's a [ __ ]
uh tell me because i got an offer to do
calgary a new venue in calgary
a new venue yeah a new venue not yuck no
not yet
i'll tell you later about it okay
but i heard their uh covert protocols
are super strict up there did you have
any issues i had to wear a mask on the
plane on the way there and in the
airport
they just stopped doing masks everywhere
june in june
they just got back to normal in june
what do you mean
normal it's not normal if you're wearing
in the airplane in math yeah you still
yeah that's not normal and you have to
have you better show proof of
vaccination to get in there you're you
know but you just show them your card or
they like no you got to show them the
card your card and then do the airline
does it you know yeah yeah but it's like
i have a fake vaccination card so if i
were to go to canada is it a database
yeah is it like
how straight this is you know
it's they they no it's just uh
you know you show them your vi your
pfizer or your maternal they don't know
what it is i mean there's a and then you
pass the date and then you go by yeah
yeah okay you don't like put it into a
computer if you're a crosstalk you don't
put it in another no they didn't like
track you and stuff right
i heard it's really strict up there no
no the media is scared it's more the
airlines that do it it's on the airlines
so they get a boarding pass you have to
check in and part of your check-in
process is to put in your passport
information put in your um
your vaccination information
canada's very thorough in terms of like
they want to know everything about you
mm-hmm yeah
um yeah trudeau so there's that you're
doing a new venue in uh it's a new
camera we'll see it depends how strict
there
so here can it's pretty
strict but everybody's vaccinated in
canada so it's not even an issue yeah i
don't think the venue is asking for it's
just really getting in there and getting
out of there you'll be fine did you have
to take a covert test to get out
do you have to take a copy test get out
no you'll be fine yeah they they make a
bigger deal about it than it is no
nobody that's what i assume nobody
nobody the truth about boosters and
vaccines is nobody can has the time to
check everybody it's like a metal
detector with a public school you don't
have time to wait yeah it's just it
would cause such a backlog so what they
do is they it's basically an honor
system they go where's your you know
them checking back
but they do want to see your card or a
picture that's fine that's awesome yeah
right maybe worth it yeah dude i saw doc
you gotta see it hey house of dragons is
so lit best show on tv right now b
there's a doc called running with the
devil you know uh mcafee the anti-virus
uh
um
like
yeah that guy's affected his own death
apparently have you seen the doc the
software the antivirus software so it's
called run with a double uh that's
definitely not it john no it's a netflix
thing
john mcafee dude
it's so good because so what happens
um is
he sells his company for whatever 300
million dollars it's worth 17 billion
now right
he worked for nasa he's a computer
program for nasa
develop all that stuff comes up with
that anti-virus software
and then
uh he moves to belize
and
his neighbor dies everyone thinks it's
him so when he thinks the government
everybody's out to get him so he goes on
the run
now when he goes on the run he doesn't
want the the media telling just one side
of the story so he hires two young
guys to film everything for him and
document all while he's on the run
wow so right away when that's happening
i go to myself
because these guys are from vice i'm
like well
if
he told them
where he's at and they come film
everything isn't that breaking the law
because then you're aren't you helping
out a fugitive who's
suspected of murder like isn't that a
crap so i'm like that's weird
whatever so they film everything he's
crazy
if they say running with the devil or
running with evil or whatever it's
called i don't think he's an evil dude i
just think he's a bit of a narcissist
clearly narcissist out of his mind
usually this young girl she's like 18 in
police
and her
uncle
he's like the highest district attorney
in the country and they they what they
want to use him to so he can get you
know
freedom and not be accused of all this
it's fascinating dude it's well they
it's called they're just sad they're
filming the whole thing in texas and
he's still alive
spoiler in three two one the documentary
ends
with you know they say commit suicide in
prison and somewhere in europe i think
or maybe the middle east
but then um suicide never made sense and
he had a tattoo it goes if i'm found
dead it's not suicide like he had a
tattoo like the media's gonna make this
seem like a suicide guarantee because i
have all this info because he was saying
he had the ability because he said he
hacked in and had uh information on
hillary clinton the cartel and the
cartel was out to get him so
he bought a yacht and again this to me
caused red flag because he'd be with the
camera guys he'd be like we have five
minutes get out of here they know where
they know where we're at so he'd have a
boat and go and i'm like i think the
government can easily chase you yeah
that sounds like a lot of theatrics i
it's tough to tell it's tough to tell
and then he ditches the 18 year old girl
after he leaves he was dating an 18 year
old he was trying to get married to her
and then he's my age then he has to yeah
and then he has to go back on the run
so he's on the run and then he gets to
he fails so he's in jail and believes
fakes a heart attack escapes
gets to miami they just chill in miami
uh mary's a prostitute a black
prostitute and that's funny they're like
oh his love at first sight she's like no
no it's just a job and then i wanted to
get out of here so i linked up with them
but she's like now yeah now i love them
now i've been around each other but yeah
he just asked me come with him i was
just a working girl you're like well
this guy's out of his mind and he's
doing all the drugs he's doing bath
salts oh those that works out for you
but so then to me so but part of it's
like all right is this guy just
a [ __ ] addict who's out of his mind
like making all this up yeah but then
they they do interview the again she's
prostitute so i don't have the most
trustworthy people but she goes people
think he's making up like she's like
meet him down this horrible fight i
called my pimp because that's when i
need you know
help i call my pimp so i called my pimp
he said i'm gonna help send somebody to
help you out and she goes and he sent uh
somebody from the cartel and the cartel
gave me she had the bag of whatever
poison she's like give me a bag of
poison put this in this dinner and he
won't wake up she's like i just couldn't
do it she's like so when people say that
the cartel stuff isn't real it's real
like i've talked with him and they
wanted me to kill him that's his wife
and she's a prostitute so take it for
what it's worth yeah but it's just it's
fascinating so so what was his
did he got arrested for the alleged
murder of his neighbor
uh which one the rich one belize was
that right
but then he escapes that saying he has a
heart attack but then he got arrested
for tax evasion
and then when he's in tax evasion in
spain
that's when he goes to prison in spain
and they're going to extradite him back
to america
he supposedly committed suicide but then
the documentary ends with that 18
year-old girl who's now a lot older a
lot heavier
she says
i just talked to him two weeks ago he's
in texas he told me to come with him he
wants to run away
oh so i don't know
it's so interesting security
but he's he's got he's got some issues
he's got some yeah like for nasa she
developed the program to get us to space
like he's a brilliant dude because he
created that anti-virus software but
then he was saying that he um
you know the card so part of the thing
is he's like one of the reasons why the
government's after me is because i
hacked into the government all these
databases i have all this information on
hillary clinton and the in the cartel
and or you broke the law well or well
here's the thing you you evaded taxes in
the documentary they say they go uh
john never released any information on
hillary clinton or the cartel you know
ever
wait wait say that again he never really
like he says he has that information no
one ever saw no that's the problem it's
like you know that that that uh dinesh
d'souza did 2 000 mules do you know that
that thing it's 2 mules it's it's
he set out to prove that the election
was rigged okay and he got four million
minutes of closed circuit tv that where
the cameras were were on the ballots on
on the ballot boxes and basically the
information the idea was that they they
had taken what is that so he was getting
subtle messages from the u.s officials
saying in effect we're coming from uh
mcafee we're going to kill
we're going to kill yourself well his
arm looks weird i got a tattoo today
just in case if i suicide myself i
didn't i was whacked check my right arm
yeah it's like a crystalia like suicide
note this is weird
this guy's
the whole thing is weird
these people are crazy
they're sometimes you got to stop and go
you're [ __ ] crazy oh well he hired a
ghost writer like to write a novel for
him because his story was pretty crazy
but i'm thinking he does admit he's like
like they're filming him he doesn't he's
like he's like i've created gold for you
i've threaded and like you know
exaggerated things to make a perfect
movie for you so it's it's it's just
it's fascinating he's out of his [ __ ]
mind but the ghostwriter goes
i don't know what's real man like
they he said his father committed
suicide when he's 17 he's like but i
have this recording and in the recording
that's like two years old he goes yeah
my dad used to beat me and my mom so bad
if i had to do something
instead of a shot in the head same way
that the guy was murdered his neighbor
was murdered and then also he clearly
murdered his neighbor i mean that's not
enough for discussion but it was his
neighbor and him and his neighbor hated
each other and his neighbor supposedly
killed his dogs and then and that night
he was on his porch in his gun in the
air say i'm gonna kill you son of a
[ __ ] and the next day the guy ends up
dead
so it's like this is in belize yeah
and the neighborhood ended up being shot
in the head right okay so sometimes back
of that so sometimes and there's no
there's no breakdown sometimes you have
to go well let's see you're shooting it
in the air you hate him
you know you can see that
uh he sounds [ __ ] crazy
and he's also one of those guys where
everything that comes out of his mouth
is a lie yeah i'm whoever says this i
agree so janice mcafee said she she was
not taking claims serious she goes we're
talking about john mcafee so anything is
possible but like the likelihood of him
being in texas and that being shared to
the world in a netflix documentary is
unlucky that's what i thought texas is a
great place but john was being held in
spanish prison because trump charges
against him from the irs and sec so i
doubt he would choose to hide out in
america
why would he hide out here when he's
already in like in
spain nobody's know who why would he
come here it sounds like he's totally
unhinged and a drug addict and also
probably lost his mind and also a
criminal and also has always gotten away
with lying
like just lying his ass off con men like
this are so good in line that they
believe their own [ __ ] lies
so
you know he regularly posted updates
from his twitter account saying he was
content with the situation and had
friends in prison scratch conditions
yeah i don't know you got to create a
bunch of like they're after get me i'm
so powerful that the government wants to
kill me it's like well my whole thing is
like you'd like right they're coming to
get me in there on this yacht and take
off to whatever the next island it's
like well if it was that easy all
criminals just get a [ __ ] boat and
take off like you don't think they can
chase well first of all they are
tracking so when you have a yacht it's
there you're in contact with that
navigation and you gotta call into the
you're like faster so you're life vest
if you fall in the water it has a
natural uh a navigation that goes right
to the coast guard of that area yeah so
sorry that doesn't fly and by the way
the live guest the life vest has to be
active i'm not saying that i'm saying
so let's say let's say you killed the
three of us in this room today and
jumped in your tesla yeah that tesla's
pinging off of all sorts yeah
so
is a yacht yeah it's easy yeah so even
then i was like super easy to catch a
yacht they're not faster
so [ __ ] off but he'd be like all right
we gotta get out and jump on the up like
oh thank god we got out of there i was
like well
you're not safe in the waters dude they
just send a speed boat or a helicopter
and shoot you down they shoot the
engines out whatever they do it all the
time yeah
yeah i don't know it was interesting guy
though it was fascinating i could i
didn't want to end yeah it was good he's
out of his [ __ ] mind
then he'd have disguises
but then he would go into this place
like a wig place or whatever and he'd
make sure they knew who he was and what
he did
and then take pictures with him how and
then he's exhausting oh his ego his ego
is out of control you should sell your
hair to him as a wig one of his wigs is
just like marks and he and uh the lady
goes should we know who you are he's
like well uh do you use mcafee virus and
she goes yeah he goes that's me and then
like you take a picture like sure but
make sure you don't post ladies like
okay oh my god this is if you're on the
run for murder why not narcissist
anybody take pictures
he just wants to be famous that's why
the document documentarian guys they're
like it's very strange because any
restaurant or anywhere we went he would
like make sure everyone knew he's there
like people that are on the run for
murder
don't give a [ __ ] about social media
see a lot of people like this if you
actually
look at what got them going at the end
of the day what do they want fame that's
right they want to be famous and we've
met a lot of people like that in la
where you see people who are really
successful and they're making all the
money and it's just getting off
why would you want to be it's what you
always say you're always like just be
rich
the best gig in the world no one's
staying in your picture nope no one's
watching all your movies got to be
famous just do your thing got to figure
out a way to be famous i'll get you
start by
by making famous friends and then you
hang out with them and then you try to
figure it out from there it's so strange
yeah very strange yeah this guy
especially at the time's documentaries
you know end of whatever last month
company was worth
17. billion dollars 17 billion
he could buy his freedom with that [ __ ]
well he bought a lot of [ __ ] did he sell
maccabee by real later yeah backfield
that's his [ __ ] he sold it i mean years
prior for like
600 million or something like that yeah
and now it's worth 17 billion billion
[ __ ]
amazing
and before that it worked for nasa so
like that's the other thing like his
background i could see that guy figure
out how to hack the government or get
into
you know hillary clinton's email so it's
it's tough dude yeah it's tough
it's [ __ ] tough
he's out of his [ __ ] mind though i
don't get it maybe let's take a little
break from all these shenanigans buddy
break a little break buddy you got to
take a break so we're going to take a
little break man i'll tell you what
doesn't break our tour man no
tour dates coming up daddy
i'm in appleton wisconsin september 8th
through the september 10th that is next
week appleton almost sold out ontario
california ontario improv september 15th
the 17th boston laugh boston i end
september tour dates with boston
september 29th through october 1st get
tickets at thinkboy.com listen guys
raleigh north carolina good night
september 8th 9th and 10th i'm i'm going
to be there i'm excited san jose
california the improv september 15 16
17. spokane washington spokane comedy
club september 22 23-24 and i'm not
stopping i'll go right to bridgeport
connecticut if i want i'll go east coast
and go to stress factory october 13 14
15. come get some it's going to be a lot
of fun
b the wait is almost over though the new
football season is almost here that's
right daddy called starts this saturday
nfl follows shortly after that can you
watch football and make money that's my
question with my friends at draftkings
official sports betting partner the nfl
to celebrate the return of football
draftkings is giving new customers a
canvas offer bet just five dollars on
any football game and get 200 in free
bets instantly you want more action cool
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion get up
seven so if your team gets up by seven
points you win even if they lose the
game they get up by seven at any point
during the game you win you get paid
instantly draftkings is safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit
withdrawal your cash when you want
download draftking sportsbook app right
now use promo code fighter you get 200
in free bets instantly when you place
five dollar bet on any football game
that's code fighter only at draftkings
sportsbook official sports betting party
the nfl minimum age eligibility
restrictions by see show notes for
details see next page for directions for
disclaimer download draftking sportsbook
app promo code fighter
fire
hey b you know those times when you're
doing that one thing can't think about
anything else or the time when you're
you're so focused they call it being in
the zone yeah i love that i love when
your brain is completely focused i just
wish there was a way to get my brain
you're talking about a little pill i'm
talking about a bill if there was some
kind of a pill like that limitless pain
yes i got you bro you're talking about
alpha brain from our friends that honest
it's the ultimate way to get there yes i
remember it's a neutrophic supplement
dude with over one million bottles hold
the story from you for a second
it's a supplement sold over one million
bottles all right alpha brain promotes
cognitive functions including memory
mental speed and focus so you feel like
you're on that limit bill brian can help
you remember names zero in on complex
tasks think more clearly under stress
all right our friend rogan says he feels
that it helps him form better sentences
when he's talking well he takes it every
guy
he takes every day and i remember him
coming up with the whole formula he got
really into nootropics and that's how
alpha brain was founded he basically put
all the ingredients together started
taking it himself and on it was born
alpha brain contains amino acids and
plant compounds that promote the brain's
release of alpha waves which are
associated with greater creativity and
productivity uh they've done
double-blind placebo tests and found
that it actually improves memory and
cognition uh it supports
neurotransmitters chemicals that relay
information in and and from the brain
uh yeah listen man if god make you
jittery either nope if coffee and energy
drinks make you all jittery well guess
what alpha brain is caffeine free so you
don't have to worry about that listen
for any reason you wanna try alpha brain
you don't like it you get your money
back just give on it two weeks if that
that point you don't feel like alpha
brain is fit for you just tell us why
and then refund your money daddy no
return necessary we got you save ten
percent on your order by going to on
it.com
f-a-t-k
all right that's on it.com f-a-t-k
we got you covered man on it alpha brain
or swing by your local walmart and pick
some up right now there you go
i just don't know why
we don't have like so just lane maxwell
she goes away to jail for trafficking
trafficking women to apparently
no one like who she she's doing 20 years
for for sex trafficking but
she had to have been trafficking those
women somewhere
who were the guys buying the women how
is that not well you know i thought we
were going to get all the
how about this how about they have the
book the black book they kept all the
names where are the names they can't
release them because some people are
still in government as we speak they
can't release the names so which is so
strange so wait so and then she was
supposed to flip she was flipping go bad
and all right well we know people who
were on the
plane but that doesn't mean you were you
were having sex with underage girls well
well no because there were women well he
had a lot of celebrities that would go
there right like chelsea handler people
like that
chelsea's not out there doing crap i'm
telling you she's not she's not one of
those people yeah but there are a lot of
people like chelsea go though well there
are a lot of people that were on the
plane who would go to this island right
but then there were guys who were really
famous who were going there to have sex
the majority would go to have sex i mean
if you have money you don't need
somebody's private jet where are the
names well wait if you're going to put
so
you're in i'm sorry what are you arguing
right now i'm saying are you saying it
didn't happen or you're saying that
these people are guilty i'm saying
something happened because they put her
away for 20 years yes right so you were
sex trafficking you took women and
whoever underage girls or whatever they
were you put them on a plane and you
flew them somewhere else for sex that i
think that's that's the definition we
have some names right prince charles uh
yeah bill clinton yeah but but no
because because
you if illegal activity was happening
who were who were the recipients of that
illegal it takes two to tango who are
the recipients of that illegal activity
and why haven't their names come up
didn't she mention who was there
but i didn't i don't have any names why
and that's why that's why they're saying
that she was gonna be off let me see go
back go go back up buddy
um okay faces six counts in her federal
trial
which relate to accusations that she
facilitated sexual exploitation of girls
for her long term time companion
disgrace finance here jeffrey epstein
uh four accusers one count of enticement
of a minor to travel to engage in
illegal sex acts in which mrs maxwell is
accused of coercing one girl identified
as minor victim one in charging
documents to travel to florida okay who
is she going to [ __ ] okay oh so who's
with mr epstein
convenient he's dead one count of
transportation of a miner
i think he'll say yeah excuse me bring
the same girl florida so it's all it's
poor epstein now yeah now
my guess is here you want to hear what
my theory is on all this okay
so
epstein apparently bought that crazy
mansion for ten dollars ten dollars
epstein apparently nobody really knows
how he was making his money but he had a
lot of money nobody knows how he had
that island but he had a lot of islands
nobody knows who really when he bought
that plane and all that he was a traitor
but there isn't really a paper trail
that shows where he got all that money
and all that influence or that he knows
anything about finances according to
eric right okay so now
so now
jaslane maxwell conveniently says i'm
going to take this 20 year
hit and i was only trafficking for mr
epstein even though we know a lot of
powerful people were there
like prince andrew who had a 17 year old
girl there on his lap and all that okay
fine picture
and that girl by the way and her team
had asked for 25 million dollars way
before it went public they said if you
want to keep this quiet give us 25
million dollars prince andrew said [ __ ]
off and then it came out okay fine
my my thing is that my my guess is my
guess is that jaslane maxwell and
jeffrey epstein worked for a foreign
intelligence agency like the mossad like
israeli foreign
secret service that's where all the
money kept funding that's where the
money came from and they wanted to get
powerful people especially men in
compromise situations that's what that
island was and and i think that the the
massage has a bunch of [ __ ] videotape
and files of the most powerful people in
the world including clinton
having sex with underage girls or
whoever it was we're just girls clinton
yeah but he's no longer somebody that
he's no longer in power so there's no
point guys
yeah hillary's my wife i paid enough was
trump ever on that plane
yeah i don't think so yes
i don't think he was
i don't think he was yeah i think that's
probably the most solid theory out there
brian
that he was on it no
sorry the mossad specifically yeah and
and the way that they operate yup
ooh
trump flew more often 17 trips
but you know you know he also had his
hand in victoria's secret too well so so
no so
wexler i believe that's his name who
owned victoria's secret and the limited
was the one who sold him the house for
ten dollars they were in cahoots
together and then epstein but waxil was
gay
yeah but all the girls yeah all the
victoria secret models it's so
interesting at least seven trips success
on this new york daily news
okay so he was
got a lot of powerful people on that
thing i mean that was their goal but i
apparently though it was hard to tell
you know i don't know how it's on these
islands with all these
horrible bodied white guys but um
the part of the problem is is like you
couldn't tell some of the girls you'd
hook up with and then i think up seemed
like hey she was 17 bro
like what again we recorded it right so
give us all the funding that's right
yeah so like it's not you know i don't
and uh in 95 he flew with his son eric
who was not two years old yet yeah
so again there were a lot of people that
went to that island because they were
invited and it was nice that's weird i
think that they strange to me well it's
the cover you you have you have people
flying there for parties and fun and
then you have people then you have the
other
group that comes for
that little naughty naughty stuff you
get the guys it's the boys weekend
that's as old as [ __ ] time it's
interesting right yeah
wow
wow i'm watching that uh fx series on
clinton and uh monica lewinsky
it's a new new series you know because
they did do they did the series they did
oj they did versace and now they're
doing bill clinton monica lewinsky so
then i just went down the rabbit hole
bill clinton like dude this guy is
accused of [ __ ] sexual assault since
[ __ ] oh yeah
oh my god lewinsky's the smallest is his
track record his track record like holy
crap and trump yeah well
clinton's is way worse than trump's
clinton's is way worse they're not
comparable you can't lump them together
clinton's is bad well in the white house
rape in arkansas when he was governor
yeah right and then and then in the
white house like um
homegirl who uh actually set it all up
uh what's her name star
uh monica no no linda tripp linda linda
tripp and then the trip she recorded the
car she recorded all of it with monica
lewis because they're really close but
linda tripp they i looked into that and
she was like i mean i don't know why
they kept putting young girls in the
[ __ ] office to work with him well he
she was like every single girl in there
he's made an advancement towards every
single one of them the the craziest one
was
where kathleen i can't remember her last
name she's beautiful and she went to him
and said my husband is suicidal because
he can't find a job can you give him a
job or help him
and
clinton had a
bunch of
like a tray of like tea and stuff and he
goes all right well hold this tray
and she held the tray
and he said she just he just started
grabbing her tits
and kissing her and she and and my
mother said i believe that story i go
why she goes because she said what a
woman would say and the first thing they
said and then what kathleen said she
goes the first thing in my mind that
went through my mind is he's gonna spill
all the tea on the rug
and my mother said that's like that's
such a thing that i would say like the
first thing you think is what the [ __ ]
are you doing like i have my hands
apparently his move was just pulling his
dick out too
look man whatever the case there's a
long list of people with the same story
so
and then all those women can homeboy
that worked for the white house and went
to college with clinton came up with him
in arkansas
he you know all this stuff starts to go
on and he knows a lot of information
about it and then he commits suicide six
months later there's a lot of suicide
going on weird yeah
and then my girl you know
what'd you say hillary clinton feminist
huh oh i know and then because the
response to finding out all these
accusations let's destroy their lives
look the the the hypocrisy is hilarious
i mean biden biden
biden almost
you know he was also uh accused of of
sexual assault and everybody who ran
with him and but kamala harris said i
believe him i believe her and she had no
problem running as he's made so the flop
was incredible yeah as soon as as soon
as you can get in a position of power
and stuff it's like yeah sorry tara reid
sorry about it then my girl was like man
poor hillary and i was like
what did you just say
i was like and she was like i bet
eventually she was probably upset with
and then she just learned how to deal
with them like but she actually
destroyed this i was like she's she went
after them i was like
bill's the least of her words yeah she's
like yeah that's old billy i think she's
gay anyway the [ __ ]
yeah the whole dynamic's weird well it's
that dirty politics man i mean there's
such a long i think if you're in
politics for that long especially in the
south like arkansas i mean anywhere
anyone's clean you're you're idiotic
none of them no it's tit-for-tat you're
dealing with they're all narcissists
you'll be crazy to be a politician yeah
you're crazy with all kinds of stuff
that mix of personalities all guys like
john
yeah mcafee tyson said something great
mike tyson they were talking about him
being great mike tested let me tell you
something about being great okay and
greatness i met a lot of people that
were great and they weren't good people
yeah my my my thing is you know i i
maybe i did some great stuff i want to
be a good person that's that's [ __ ]
difficult yeah it's like a simple idea
but yeah i don't think i'm always yeah
let's pause this first engine because
you raped a girl right so yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean yeah yeah went to
but i did seven years for it yeah yeah
six years
but i'm always amazed at uh
when you meet people that are hyper
successful a lot of times i am always
kind of
amazed at how flawed they can be i mean
everyone's flawed yeah
but also just
like madonna at 64 years old
still well but fame is a different
famous i mean honey she's fighting the
good fight she's trying
or nicole kidman 55 years old i mean i
don't know what she's doing to her face
but that skin regimen is something like
it yeah that does not move bro
i mean that that's like
like 55 but there's success
fame and success especially when you're
madonna you're known for that trying to
be age proof to me tough dude time to be
age proof is a [ __ ] take a look at the
picture of her on her birthday her
birthday yeah 64th
64 year old birthday
and nicole nicole's just doing whatever
she is fighting that [ __ ] her face does
not move she's my age 55 years old
i mean that's not easy
look at her on the cover of that perfect
though that's recent that's right that's
my most recent cover
55.
that's a lot of work she's pretty good
oh yeah
go go down let me see there are a bunch
of pictures over there but fame
especially when beauty is part of your
like that's your thing other one oh this
yeah i can't think of jlo jayla's 50.
well j.lo is a freak of nature
jayla's a freaking nature that's that's
just a that's a that's a lot of work
right there though that's
yeah fame and getting older in the
public spotlight it has to be tough and
we're just judy's like one of your
things you're addicted she's actually a
great [ __ ] actress too oh yeah
but you're addicted to that
i get fighting young and you can see now
the age though it's not
you just got it sometimes
but there's way worse examples than
nicole kidman cool kids well madonna's
nicole kim is actually winning the fight
10-9 yes madonna's down 10-8 in the
rounds oh madonna but at
well that's another weird thing too
that's like what i don't know what she's
yeah it's like wait nobody gets an ass
at 70. well it's yes doesn't get fatter
she's doing
the kind of [ __ ] she's doing
yeah it's a rough one
how old is he 64 sir i mean she's doing
the damn thing she's doing the damn
thing you got to give it up
it must be a process in the mornings i
would imagine there's a lot of work to
be done
but uh
they've been madonna booty she's still
wearing
yes she's trying to be young at that age
she's like what are you doing here
but i guess what's the alternative there
we go this is her robots no no but go to
her 65 year old you can see what she's
wearing that her birthday her 65 year
old
65th that that'll be honest
this is right now those are pictures
that butt is so weird what are you doing
seriously but i bet my question what
should they do b just give up
i i think that you have to uh
sir you had your lids done i i know but
you have to let it go after a while you
you have to realize that you are
you're you're looking now you're being
ridiculous the ass is ridiculous i i
agree with that but the face stuff i get
for women i get it it's a lot of
pressure man
the ass is just absolutely insane i mean
what are you thinking yeah
my thing is it speaks to something much
deeper but anyway
oh boy
yeah that's tough yeah she's uh 64.
doing it looks like a cartoon yeah
it's hilarious though yeah
so okay
there we go
i want to live forever
the worst are the guys that
when the guys go too deep that's the
worst that's the worst
that's the worst like uh who is that
country singer
um keith urban i don't know kenny rogers
do you think of the connection he's good
but there was another one roy uh
who who's saying the football who's
saying football oh uh
how are you ready for some fun are you
ready for some football he's had work
done oh bob oh you're right now that you
that's carrie underwood
hank
williams is that some work
yeah you might want to take a look at
that no really i don't yeah i never
thought he did i think you think of a
wrong guy hank doesn't seem like you got
to do it i might be thinking of the
wrong way yeah because
i don't think so that's just a lot of
makeup kenny rogers had like he had his
legs done a lot he's done wrong
when i have my lids done the doctor goes
you're just going to look less sleepy
it's not nobody's going to see much
that's like a lot yeah that's
come on man also that there's a
difference you get a brow lift so those
guys are getting browsed so they're
getting their you get your you get this
look
the shape of the eyes
and yeah you start doing that kind of
[ __ ] boy you better be careful
if i ever come in i mean he looks good
though right i mean he looks a little
crazy
but
i mean i'm looking forward to doing that
yeah
you're going to do a lot of that you
yeah i'd rather look like that than mark
martin 100 mark you are what you're
going to be the male madonna i i vow to
document all of it because you say like
oh you do botox and lip fillers i'm like
the moment i do that you think i'm not
going to make youtube content out of it
follow my journey
yeah you both have very nice plump lips
naturally yes
i you know
i'd rather look like that than look like
a [ __ ] sharpay you know yeah like if
your skin's just melting i'm like doc we
gotta do this this is a mess man i
wouldn't give him the more bread i sent
you a picture this weekend of me as a
three-year-old you can verify yeah i've
always had big lips
are fat
none of us want to die some dsls what
none of us want to die
no and that's what that's what that's
the example you're doing fame's a
different animal though fame and beauty
is your thing like they're going to
fight that to the [ __ ] grave you call
it's called raging against the knight
oh that's like they took that from
raging against the machine right raise
no rage against the knight
you can you can grow old gracefully or
you can rage against the night yeah
there's some yes some dudes look like
sean connery before he passed away he's
[ __ ] dying oh yeah he didn't give a
[ __ ] good genetics though yeah
yeah
that's good if you're like a holly like
okay jack nicholson
like there comes a point where it's like
hey man if i'm if i can make movies
whatever i want do i need to get work
done do you think it's like yeah robert
de niro but also those guys have never
been like
hot leading men like let's look at jason
momoa in about 30 years let's see what
happens then when you're known for looks
like bradley cooper like some of these
dying brad pitt i don't think brad
pitt's had any work done i don't know if
he has
i don't know his hairline is
suspiciously full at five he's heavy
he's always had good hair
i can tell you that i don't know 55
though yeah like tonight he's older than
that you know yeah a little suspicious i
saw this recently of bradley cooper
his body looks like a dime
yeah he lost weight his body's like like
a young dude's body yeah i'm saying like
shaved chest
he looks like a kid there
i'd be smiling like that too though
but this picture was kind of um not
controversial but it would raise some
questions because he's supposed to be
with huma remember
anthony weiner's ex
but then he was on vacation they have
they share a kid together so i think
that's what their son you know hanging
out together and she's ridiculously
she's a super hot model she was like you
want to go to this pig island he's like
[ __ ] yeah
oh yeah that's that island we're there
what island is that hey see because
there he doesn't look like that no
that's that's what's funny his body is
there he's actually what is he wearing i
don't know dude you knew you're gonna be
photographed dude
yeah
but that's a huma right there oh huh
well
well
but he looks great very smart we're
going to pig island dude
what island is that with all those
piggies oh let's look
he could have done a cut just for the
vacation you know
just says tropical vacation vacation
there's an island there's an island just
full of pigs
so you want to go brendan
yeah i won't be in pig island
depending on how far the flight is
oh you think she listed it yeah that was
supposed to be on her thing
let's see what it says here
bahamas little heart with a pig
yeah he's in shape
but you know usually when people get
older they have like
my friends call old man muscle where
everything kind of droops a little bit
yeah it just kind of comes down a little
bit yeah but his looks like an actual
young dudes
46 or something it's not that old that's
yeah that's
that's very impressive
not really
don't think his body is impressive it's
okay oh man it's okay that's pretty
impressive all right anyways
but also this movie stars
that's your job yeah you know what i
mean if that's all you do and you always
had i mean his body in a team was pretty
unbelievable you ever see him in that in
a team yeah yeah he's [ __ ] jacked in
that that's where he's like [ __ ]
yeah
yeah it looks great but also like hey
studio is paying for six months of
training and diet you know all this
stuff well i'm taking everything under
the sun you don't have anything to do
besides uh he didn't i i talked to him
about that he didn't take any drugs
there he wasn't doing steroids he was
just lifting he that's how bradley is
like bradley's built that way i've known
him for like he was always like when he
was working out that's what he looks
like he didn't look crazy he's a stud he
just looks great yeah he's like crazy
though he's lean yeah he's super lean
that's what he can everybody looks good
at nine percent body fat yeah yeah yeah
and he's got a good frame
yeah he's a legit six one broad
shoulders although we'll say i i believe
that he's not on anything here if he
said that but
also everyone's gonna deny it you know
no no i mean i don't think you should
see him no
i would assume like you assume
athletes are i would assume yeah also
i don't know why you wouldn't has any
actor come out and said i've done
steroids not once no but not in that
movie not once no but i believe him
i don't believe any of them
um
what else you got jen
what's the
the indian guy the new marvel
oh kamel kamal
himself
without a doubt without a doubt without
a doubt and ryan reynolds in blade two
like these are easy yeah casey salt
fellas
why wouldn't you or ben affleck can't
talk about it yeah ben affleck i know
bradley cooper is the biggest in uh
american sniper he's huge oh he's like
actually like 240 yeah
so uh did you guys watch the vmas at all
because
i did watch it explain why i was weird i
don't mind john jeff being there like
you they they had like
yeah they had like a floating uh you
know tv man that's an astronaut they
imposed johnny's face in it yeah it just
wasn't very funny it was weird like i
had to do this because i need jobs
everybody
you know you're like all right they
would end or start every second so he
was he was in he i think this is like
the mtv music awards he floats up in a
spacesuit
but it's his face imposed on it like
digital
i needed the work
[Applause]
so that was like one of them say
anything
let's get back to the music shall we
[Applause]
i just want you guys to know that i'm
available for birthdays bar mitzvahs
batman's was weddings weeks
any old thing you need anything
[Music]
[Applause]
very weird it wasn't funny
but i don't want him being there yeah
amber heard sister got upset with it
well that's great
so you're discussing clearly desperate i
really hope that none of the people that
made this call
have daughters
i stand with amber heard what's your
sister i know
got to stand with your sister die
whatever
yeah
yeah but if they had amber would any guy
post that no what's that i said it would
if if mtv hired amber to do that cameo
would any guy be upset they'd be like
this is hilarious we don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i'd actually like that now that's
funny yeah like her doing that actually
that would be way funny way funnier she
lost way that's way better yeah i'll do
anything that's the choke that's the
hook the joke is that you're honestly
obvious yeah 100 right never heard be
funny that would be that is the joke i'm
available for anything that'd be people
would love it yeah
yeah they would have yeah yeah that's a
wonder because she actually can't find
work giant upscale yeah the irony would
be perfect yeah that's the joke
all right so like dude you got 300
million offer to play [ __ ] sparrow
again he's back
this is a pretty crazy one
so this body washed up in a beach in
thailand ass up like that yeah
decapitated too oh
but it turned out to be a sex doll
so it's like a discarded sex doll that
it was i guess it was like discarded
somewhere in a river and it ended up
washing up into the beach and freaking
people out looked like that yeah
that's what the kind of thing if you're
with your kids you go run away go go
over there i have to check this out oh
my god all right i wouldn't even [ __ ]
that's how you even check it out well
i'll just call authorities yeah that's
right i wouldn't be like i mean you
might have to see i'd have to see uh
you know you gotta i don't know my
fingerprints on it nothing well i mean
you want to make sure that whoever is
family is missing their you know that's
what i call authorities
jesus that's [ __ ] up
here's a yacht sinking in italy yeah
this was exactly the same yacht i was on
apparently what yes you're kidding
exactly the same yacht that this is what
i was just talking about
how did this work
the waters are too rough they were
taking on water they were taking on
water they don't know why they started
but during the hall yeah but they don't
know they're still investigating it but
they don't know why it's okay look at
that dude dude the amount of money in
that [ __ ] yacht oh yeah all the
furniture the cds it's tied to a tugboat
but the waters were too crazy so the
cookbook couldn't get it out so it's
lost oh my god
now we'll see you later that is the end
they think way slower than you think
don't they yeah have you guys done
cruises and stuff before no i hate
cruises my dad took my own kid i hated
it yeah i don't trust him i'm a fan of
boats and that's one of the reasons
cruises don't make sense you're just on
a hotel in the water
well i talked to the guy who was the
captain of the yacht i said have you
ever been seas that were and he said i
it's hard for me to talk about because
it was off the iris the north iris sea
or something or and i almost we almost
died but they were in a yacht and the
[ __ ] so oh so you did talk about it
though yeah so the boat the yacht would
be at the crest of a wave and then do
this he's like i can't tell you this
sure
well no he said talking about it gives
me ptsd freaked out yeah because he
would be up there and then just
jump down you would drop so the the wave
takes you that high and then there's
only one way down
oh my [ __ ] god
and he was in a big yacht doing that
yeah they almost died
because if you get in the water there
it's so cold
you die
nobody can rescue you
you're done also but they made it out of
it they don't even wear a lot of those
guys don't wear life vests because it
just makes you it prolongs it you're
just cold
but they were fine
they made it out
um do you guys remember daisy fontes yes
she was like the hottest guy
for mtv yep
uh so she recently got on tick tock and
a lot of comments were how different she
looked because she's 50 years old now
she's like way younger obviously when
she's on mtv super beautiful girl yeah
she's so pretty uh so but i just like
her come back
hi guys um she's really pretty yeah
she's 50 15 years ago many of you were
so surprised to see me here and you were
wondering if it really was me and it is
it's it's me um i don't know when the
last time was that you saw me but yeah i
look different i do look different you
know i don't know if you saw me 15 years
ago 20 years ago but hey i'm in my 50s
now and yes i look different
maybe you look different from the last
time that you saw me too
maybe yeah and no i haven't gotten
surgery yet i may i don't know she's
gorgeous
people are complaining
yeah i use filters because why not
look good and this gives me the option
to so yes i use filters hey if you want
to see me ugly
come to my house
and bring pizza good for her by the way
she married a very wealthy industrialist
like like a billionaire that makes sense
well she's now with richard marks i'm
out with who richard marks the singer
yeah the songwriter singer okay not my
favorite singer but
he wrote so many hit songs like so many
for instinct and a bunch of people yeah
i assume she made it rich and i just was
like see ya she married some really rich
billionaire and then from there
hollywood sia is right who the [ __ ]
needs this shoe is gorgeous yeah well so
me and uh brendan talked about
uh jake paul having a fight i guess this
was october
right but he didn't say any like names
or whatever but anyways before that rick
ross said that he would give an
additional 10 10 million dollars onto
the purse for the people whoever fights
so much money jake paul yeah
and so he does and then shortly after
that jake announced the fight i was like
i'll do that who's who's who is he
fighting we don't know yet
he's gonna probably be announced uh
later this week or next week who would
you choose if you could for him uh an
idiot
yeah
that's a good idea yeah that's a really
good idea biggest fight
i just saw this recently on instagram
it's just phil heath he's looking
ridiculous right now jack city in his
40s
[Music]
now finally somebody who's not on
steroids
he's great jacked yeah he's the man yeah
it just looked crazy he's a little
different he does he looks a lot bigger
son of a [ __ ]
uh marcus
yes
i sent you one there yeah elon was heavy
for a second did you see uh
this just reminded me of it do you see
zuckerberg on rogan
i did not i want to watch it what'd you
think
i don't know man yeah he's a robot
that's how i felt i thought i was
like dude but rogan will get it out of
you you know
but
his body was really bad he's also liked
it so yeah what we're looking at here
elon musk revealed over the weekend that
he has embraced intermittent fasting
weeks after the billionaire faced some
online trolling after photos surfaced of
him lounging shirtless
near mykonos
uh he's down over 20 pounds from his
unhealthy
white and also
i mean he's very white right here that's
a very white sunscreen white yeah
yeah his butter's tough he's enjoying
the good life yeah you feel bad for him
or like is your attitude like
you're a billionaire figured out or i i
think he's just been trying to get to
[ __ ] mars or where the [ __ ] he's
doing so he's like
what yeah yeah i eat [ __ ] mcdonald's
and he's probably like you still deal
with you're still a human being and if
people are trolling you you're still a
little bit like oh you know yeah like i
got into [ __ ] i get into
a hot tub at this spa thing yeah and
it's a bunch of people in there you know
and you know you're in a you're in
shorts you still have a little body
there's more for you you know you're
yeah
and this girl goes uh she just literally
really loud goes are you brian callan
i'm like ah and all her friends are
there it's like a bachelorette party and
they're all looking at me and because my
boyfriend's such a huge fan i'm such a
huge fan of it yeah and it's just can i
take a picture of that and it's just
like now i'm like taking a picture with
my shirt off and i'm like oh man and i
got my invisalign in and i'm old think
about it austin like those pictures he's
out of his control too that's paparazzi
you just you just you just feel like you
also wear shirt if you can go to the
beach yeah elon it's hard not to feel a
little insecure
all eyes on you but with his resources
yeah it'd be pretty easy for him to get
in shape yeah now it also goes to the
idea of fat shaming being an effective
or ineffective health essentially fat
chain and now he's down 20 pounds yeah
fat shaming is probably the most [ __ ]
effective thing of all time in a way you
know all of us i
i think everybody in this room has
enough body dysmorphia to
you know i mean it's not like we work
out every day because we're really happy
with the way we look
right i mean right yeah so i guess it's
you know
i shame myself
yeah that's what i mean yeah i don't
need the internet that's what i mean
all right
one second i don't know why you guys
have any issues
but all right this is a little
interesting
liver king uh clip the guy's asking him
what about you know because people
always have this retort what about
medicine and life spans and stuff like
that you know because
his perspective perspectives every you
know he doesn't actually say everything
ancestral is great but
here you go let it play no because we
didn't we weren't taking penicillin
right then but now we have we have stuff
that doesn't let us die
about this related to this um i i like
the acute medicine that we have today
right but a lot of the long-term [ __ ]
that we do is to our detriment like well
um so let me let me tell you this people
always make this criticism oh yeah
you're promoting the ancestral living
but our early ancestors lived to 30.
this is what people say all the time
stupid [ __ ] like this right and here's
the fact is you call what we're doing
today living you call going to a job
that you hate coming home to a life you
don't love
netflix sedating yourself just enough
with medication to get hard and to be
happy call that a day called a week
called a month this is your [ __ ] life
you call that living this is how we
exist today about like medicine and [ __ ]
though not everyone but also i'm a fan
of liver kings but also
he makes a good point but
the the issue with you know when they
like the medieval times or even back
then with like the average lifestyle was
30. that's because like one out of
[ __ ] two children died when they're
infants yeah but there's a lot of people
there's a lot of
so
that cuts the lives but there were
people in their 70s 80s 90s yeah
but there were definitely definitely
vaccines and antibiotics and all those
things that make that push us beyond our
biology yeah and good nutrition and
sanitation yeah and he also makes a
distinction between acute medicine
like penicillin and chronic medic
because you know
what's the big number big pharma is like
well they're trying to get you hooked on
it for the rest of your life addicted
yeah yeah
let's see you got a bunch of those up
there yeah i have a ton but we'll see
what we're going to use here
there's not
i saw an article about this this isn't
it's a robbery but let's just look at
the video it's uh
two guys going after someone and they're
on a motorcycle and then a good
samaritan comes in
[Music]
so chase him down
[Music]
they say they try to grab his chain
so that's the gun the guy grabbed that's
a gun
[Music]
nope
that guy's a badass yeah so they're
looking for these people they don't know
who they are but the guy the fact that
the guy was a good samaritan and you
know stopped that thing from happening
was pretty well have you seen now in
brazil the new law
that allows uh they passed a law that
says if you see a motorcycle robbing
somebody you're allowed to run it over
you've seen the compilation of
brazilians killing dudes on motorcycles
just chomping at them
oh dude it's [ __ ] on instagram it's
crazy cars are just like these guys like
holding these people up this car just
goes
boom they just go flying i mean it's
crazy brazilians don't [ __ ] around
they're like oh really we get to kill
these [ __ ] on motorcycles
okay i don't know how man shoots
daughter's ex-boyfriend during break-in
so the ex-boyfriend was breaking into
the house yeah
and gets shot
yeah chilling ring camera video shows
the moment an ohio homeowner shot and
killed his daughter's ex-boyfriend as he
tried to break in what was he trying to
get
he was just trying to see her
oh sh they're in the house yeah it's
clear that look at all the cars out
front
it's the middle of the day so he's
trying to break down the door
oh he's just walking away too that's
kind of crazy
uh he looked really chill for having
just been shot yeah wow you he probably
died right there right yeah the first
one got him and then
that was wow i can't believe he can play
the new york post
let me see that again that's [ __ ]
nuts man
yeah you just walk away and die pretty
much [ __ ]
um
now he did shoot through the door are
you allowed to do that well no he busted
open the door and then he got oh
oh
see this he looks like he's not even all
there either his face is out of it
see this
see that
then he gets it open
and the dad's saying i got a gun too
i don't know i feel like that that could
be
yeah liability uh well if he broke in
and the door opened right and he's
coming in you're allowed once you make
once you step into the like you cross
the foyer but he's already in his
property um
oh through a window yeah i don't know
what's going on there
all right well now the daughter says dad
there's nothing you could have done you
saved my life according to the stage but
was he coming there to kill the daughter
like you have so many questions she
didn't know either because she's going
she's in the background going dad is he
trying you're doing this
dad he is trying to kill me yeah if
you're if you're oh that's different if
you're
trying to kill me if you're my daughter
and you're and you're the ex-boyfriend
ex-boyfriends kill their girl hold up
hold up time earlier this month the
shelby county grand jury voted eight to
one against indicting a dad on charges
relating to his kills he's good stand
your ground
yep
stand your grand law which says the
homeowner does not have a legal duty to
retreat you're trying to break into the
and and obviously being violent toward
her
i mean yeah he's [ __ ] up but if he's
um
well the sister goes far in the paint i
hope your days are more miserable than
they've ever been your disgusting excuse
of human being along with your daughter
man if someone's trying to kill one of
my kids and i showed them i wouldn't
lose an ounce not an ounce
yeah that was my question like why was
he trying to break in the house
obviously he's not collecting good well
first of all boyfriend it's obviously
he's not taking no for an answer you're
trying to come into the house and he's
yelling you have to assume
that he is there to do something bad to
her and you're her father
now i think it's better to wait till the
doors open if you shoot through the
window that seems a little bit
uh
yeah
um but you know she got you i can't
believe new york showed him getting shot
like that that's cool yeah
this i just saw last week so the
prime minister of finland was in trouble
because she was partying i mean she's so
hot by the way yeah but she's very good
and she looks super young too you've
seen her she's hot so why should she
travel for a party well so uh in her
residency she's the nerdy one with the
bangs in the front she's right here the
one dancing like wiggling
on the left
and why can't she party no that's fine
good so apparently she had there's a
picture like this that was taken in her
house
two uh topless girls making out okay so
that i guess that's like frowned upon
there i mean i i i endorse it
i don't get that
i don't need help but she can't control
what pictures people post and she
partied i guess before she got shed in
trouble for it that's her and this is
her apologizing
she's dancing with girls here as well i
understand because she's a politician
she can't she's prime minister of god
she's just too hot yeah people are
probably pissed and she's young 36 yeah
prime minister yes that's her again
this is her apologizing
[Music]
she speaks in english
so she took a drug test she said just to
prove that she was on drugs i don't know
just for her safety for everyone
she's she's still gorgeous no one's
gonna be talking about this next week
any
work meetings planned for that weekend
uh they are confirmed usually uh
beforehand and i didn't have any
meetings for example saturday or sunday
sounds almost irish yeah she's very
totally irish like
how they talk there of course through
her to your teeth
but we didn't have any government
meetings during that week and i we
didn't have any government was she not
supposed to be a human and have fun with
her friend yeah their friends
brandon and i agree i think you're fine
[ __ ] them
politicians want to stay at home and
watch tv do some drugs do some dancing
kiss girls just do what we have to do
when i'm not
oh boy okay so oh no no no oh this is
fantastic so abercrombie did tweet this
before
earlier but then they deleted because
how many people are going at him like
you're promoting obesity and you can't
help you can't win yeah so she has a
really pretty face no let's not get
carried okay so she has a pretty face
yeah a cute face
even that would be i don't like normal
stress she's she's
so heavy and not an example of how
someone says new abercrombie fish just
dropped this this season they are
featuring diabetes and it's hilarious
yeah i don't know how how long do we
just pretend we ignore this like yeah
what are we the fupa like there's
nothing healthy here what are you
including so so you're gonna sell
clothes that way okay good luck well now
though well i mean they've deleted the
post so yeah yeah right someone had to
get out because ari spears went hard at
uh um um
lizzo
and you know ours spirits isn't exactly
the epitome of health and people like
hold up this fat dude's gonna shame
uh lizzo when lizzo every weekend they
have a good point though lizzo every
weekend's on roller skates dancing for
two hours on the stage like she is
healthy just don't let the fat fool you
i'm like well
i don't know dude like are there healthy
fat people no i don't think so can there
be because because that fat
covers the organs everything too you
know it's not healthy it can't be
healthy it's not healthy for you if you
you're your body's doing well when you
had covid was when you were seriously
overweight yeah
let's stop let's stop pretending let's
stop pretending with this [ __ ] it's
just it's it's unbelievable well now the
backlash now the company's like oh we
came well it goes back and forth
like can you roller skate for an hour
it's let me see your vo2 max what's your
blood pressure what's your yeah vital
signs
so even if your heart like even if you
are rollerblading for two hours on stage
it says uh
cardiovascular it's not good
yeah yeah let's see run a mile in eight
minutes
it's just your body's in the way your
body's awake that girl was really
overweight yeah and
and just there's nothing attractive
about that and i don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody says and you can pretend and the
people who are using her are doing it
they're they're exploiting her because
nobody there
have sex with no and nobody there thinks
it's healthy but abercrombie and fitch
wants to sell a [ __ ] product you know
by by pretending they're so [ __ ]
virtuous and so egalitarian let's come
back on them just come back yeah yeah
corporations make me sick when they do
this and they deleted it which is the
language you're gonna be so dishonest
everybody some of the companies like
guys this has gotten too far and that
girl that girl has you know she should
lose weight
for her own sake and her own health it's
not attractive no it's not good i mean
there are people who do find the
attraction it's called a fetish
but still i mean it's healthy
doesn't mean it's healthy
i don't know why that's the first time
i've ever heard that but i love it how
is that the first time i've ever heard
that that's good fetish thank you sir
uh this is just chef bezos posting a
picture about
having a burger at mcdonald's and that
was his very first job at mcdonald's i
didn't know that
did you guys know that yeah i did i feel
like most people's burgers just the
first ones are mcdonald's no no that's
his first job
we actually worked at mcdonald's as a
cook
he's awesome
why is rogan trending
because of zuckerberg click on it
um is it where
yeah
sp zuckerberg right
covet 19 restrictions to vote republican
[Music]
yeah joe rogan says he would tell people
outraged by covet restrictions to vote
republican of course
jump all over this
i don't know it seems like interesting i
mean yeah i mean because you can really
only vote one or two ways so if you vote
the other way
you're fully if you're upset by this
then vote that on twitter
during the election because of the
hunter biden laptop story the new yeah
yeah so you guys you hear them admit
this they [ __ ] up the fbi i think
basically came to us
some folks on our team was like hey
um
just so you know like you should be on
high alert there was
we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be some kind of dump of um
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg making that
shocking revelation this week about
facebook suppression of the hunter
binding laptop story right before the
2020 presidential election funny how
that happens joe koncha joins us now joe
here's
yeah
well okay
i think that the uh just as a little
thing i think that roe v wade thing is
is really hurting republicans and i
think that that republicans that are the
the candidates that are trump crazy that
love trump a lot of americans are like
uh
because then today you know that sucked
in today there's bigger issues right for
the majority of people yeah
but yeah it's definitely not helping
them no
what are sketching i think that's pretty
much it that's it what about some more
stuff who sells her
no so i saw an updated thing like it was
[ __ ] yeah what's she selling
virginity and apparently some hong kong
businessman that had a ton of money like
it was going to do it for 2.5 million or
something all right well listen guys
i know a couple things i know that in uh
september 8th 9th and 10th i'm at
raleigh north carolina good night and
the weekend after that 17 18 15 16 17
i'm in san jose california at the improv
and then i go to spokane washington
spokane comedy club september 22 23 24.
a good little run there yeah best of uh
we're doing really well with that
episode i'm about to drop the tim
kennedy episode this week best of so
look for that that's coming and brian
can you damian on there dania i'm gonna
have to reschedule actually
so i have to reschedule that i'll let
you know uh for me tour wise this
wednesday we got david spade michael
rapport myself one show one night only 8
pm at the hollywood improv we also have
another very special guest on their
announce soon
but then regular tour starts back up
next week uh september 8th through the
10th appleton wisconsin then i'm in
ontario california ontario improv
september 15-17 tonight and september in
boston last boston september 29th
through october 1st come get some boston
but uh appleton wisconsin almost sold
out get tickets right now we might add
shows that's september 8th through the
10th give your tickets right now
f-a-t-k-z.com or thinkboy.com
thinkpoint.com also new merch you have
the nba quality jerseys and shorts and
hat the hat i'm wearing right now those
just dropped as well uh thickboy.com for
all that all right love you guys this is
fire kid we're out